I put together specifically, I got invited to give a keynote at Pacific C++, and it happened to coincide with the 30th anniversary of generic programming. So it was 30 years after Alex Steppenoff and Dave Musser coined the term generic programming. And I thought it really deserved a proper covering of kind of the history of generic programming and where it came from and why it's a thing. And so I put together that talk. I'm pretty proud of the talk because I ran it past Alex before I gave it, and Alex's comment was that he couldn't do it better himself. Plus Under the Sea, but this episode is pure chaos. We talk about generic programming, but also bikes, buses, waffles, and more. And with that, we will transition to not Sean Parrott, but Sean Parent.
我专门准备了这次演讲，当时我受邀在 Pacific C++ 大会上做主旨演讲，恰逢泛型编程诞生 30 周年。那是 Alex Steppenoff 和 Dave Musser 提出“泛型编程”这一术语 30 年后。我觉得非常有必要对泛型编程的历史、起源及其存在意义进行一次恰当的梳理。所以我准备了那场演讲。我对此感到非常自豪，因为我在演讲前请 Alex 审阅过，他的评价是他自己也做不到更好。此外，虽然本集内容纯属混乱，我们聊了泛型编程，但也聊了自行车、公交车、华夫饼等等。接下来，我们将转场，不是去见 Sean Parrott，而是 Sean Parent。
Apparently we're getting T-shirts made, according to Bryce. The idea is the T-shirt would have the parrot, but with like, You know, a cartoonized version of Sean's face on it. How do we feel about that, Sean? There's a bobblehead of me from CBPCon, so... Wait, you have a bobblehead? I have a bobblehead, yes. I don't have said bubblehead.
据 Bryce 说，我们好像要定制 T 恤。构思是 T 恤上印着那只鹦鹉，但换成 Sean 的卡通脸。Sean，你觉得怎么样？我在 CBPCon 上有个摇头娃娃，所以……等等，你有摇头娃娃？我有，是的。我还没见过那个摇头娃娃。
You have a Sean Pairn? Bubblehead. I may have one. I could maybe try to find it for your wedding, buddy. It's a pretty good wedding gift, folks. I mean, it sounds like a limited edition item, so there's probably a fixed number in the world. so we were trying to I mean we recorded a couple months ago or do we have to start leaving?
你有一个 Sean Pairn？摇头娃娃。我可能有一个。伙计，我或许可以试着在你的婚礼上把它找出来。这可是个很棒的结婚礼物，各位。我是说，这听起来像是限量版，所以世界上可能只有固定数量。所以我们当时在尝试……我是说我们几个月前录过音，还是说我们得开始离开了？
I don't know Oh I see you We're being kicked out I mean we can I guess you're leaving to the The train soon Are you going straight from here or I mean we can go
我不知道，哦，我看到你了，我们要被赶走了。我是说，我们可以……我想你很快就要去赶火车了，你是直接从这儿走，还是说我们可以……
I think I'd be We can go to the hotel Oh yeah that's true We'll go to the hotel Um So wait actually Do we have to leave right now Should we pause this
我想我会……我们可以去酒店。哦，对，没错。我们要去酒店。嗯，等等，其实我们现在必须离开吗？我们应该暂停一下吗？
And then resume at the hotel Or do we have like 10 minutes I don't know Are we being told to leave right now Is there a bus? If there's a bus, let's get more information. I think we should pause for now and get more information. All right, folks.
然后到酒店再继续？还是说我们还有 10 分钟？我不知道。我们现在被告知要离开了吗？有公交车吗？如果有公交车，我们再多打听一下。我觉得我们应该先暂停，去了解更多信息。好了，各位。
We were here with Sean at the venue. We talked to a bunch of folks, everyone but Sean, even though that's how we started this off. We said, we're about to talk to Sean, and then we talked to like six different people, and you got collected by a couple different people. Is there a bus coming? I have no idea, but we should get out.
我们刚才和 Sean 在会场。我们和很多人聊过，除了 Sean，尽管我们一开始是这么打算的。我们说我们要去采访 Sean，结果我们和六个不同的人聊了，而你被好几个人拉走了。有公交车来吗？我不知道，但我们得走了。
Okay. There you go. We can also record outside at the bus station. We've never recorded at a bus station. Are you still recording? Yeah, you want to see something? Yeah. So Bryce this morning, he sent out on the Slack channel,
好吧。就是这样。我们也可以在公交车站外面录音。我们从没在公交车站录过音。你还在录吗？是的，你想看个东西吗？好的。Bryce 今天早上在 Slack 频道发消息说，
like he doesn't know whether he can find his way to the venue because he couldn't get a cab within an hour. But we're in a European city, right? We have buses running every 15 minutes, and they're on time and they're on Google Maps. They're easily discoverable. So, like, everybody just wondered, like, why can Bryce just take the bus, right? Connor, do you know?
他不知道能不能找到去会场的路，因为他一小时内打不到车。但我们在欧洲城市，对吧？我们有每 15 分钟一班的公交车，而且准时，还能在谷歌地图上查到。很容易找到。所以，大家都纳闷，为什么 Bryce 不能直接坐公交车呢？Connor，你知道吗？
Listen, folks, I would love to side with you, but I was also in the position of not being able to find an Uber. I looked in the public transit. It said it was going to be 30 minutes, and at that point I had wasted 15 minutes ordering and canceling three different Uber's, and had already waited five minutes into a 19-minute wait for an Uber. It's actually not the fault. We discovered today that a lot of the trains ended up being canceled. And that's why Uber's, because last year, I Ubered a couple times to and from. We never had this issue.
听着，各位，我很想站在你们这边，但我当时也处于打不到 Uber 的境地。我查了公共交通，显示需要 30 分钟，而那时我已经浪费了 15 分钟去下单又取消了三辆不同的 Uber，而且在 19 分钟的等待时间里已经等了 5 分钟。这其实不是我的错。我们今天发现很多火车最终被取消了。这就是为什么 Uber 会这样，因为去年我往返时都打过 Uber，从没遇到过这个问题。
I did look into public transit, and I had to walk like five minutes. The whole thing was going to take 27 minutes. And look at that, the Nvidia backpack, folks. I've had mine for six years now, and it's as good as new. It's a good backpack. Bryce and I had the same problem today that we were trying to get here. And honestly, I think the solution is either the hotel or the conference to just have, like, rentable bikes for, like, 10 euros a day or something.
我确实查了公共交通，我得走大约 5 分钟。全程需要 27 分钟。看看那个，Nvidia 的背包，各位。我的已经用了六年了，还像新的一样。这是个好背包。Bryce 和我今天遇到同样的问题，我们都在设法赶到这儿。老实说，我觉得解决方案要么是酒店，要么是会议方，提供那种每天 10 欧元左右的租用自行车。
something, because that's when we were in Orhus, in Denmark. This is the Netherlands way, right? It's like, you just ride a bike. I mean, the problem is that all the locals don't have one bike. I've heard that it's per capita. There's more bikes than there are people. And so there is no need for a more elaborate infrastructure, which I actually love. I love that, you know, Netherlands in Europe in general, it's more eco-friendly, it's better
之类的，因为我们在丹麦奥胡斯时就是这样。这就是荷兰的方式，对吧？就是骑自行车。问题是当地人不止有一辆车。我听说人均自行车拥有量比人口还多。所以不需要更复杂的基建，我其实很喜欢这一点。我喜欢荷兰，喜欢欧洲，总的来说，它更环保，对你的健康更好，等等等等。所以我其实并没有对 Uber 生气。我只是想快点到那儿。但我查了一下，这里不像其他地方那样有随处可见的 Lime 或 Bird。他们有滑板车和自行车。比如我们在哥本哈根时，几次直接骑上 Lime 自行车，掏出手机扫个二维码就能出发。我觉得在荷兰，它们没那么普及，因为每个人自己都有很多自行车。所以如果你不是本地人，你多少有点倒霉。
for your health, yada, yada, yada. So I wasn't actually upset at Uber. I just wanted to get there faster. But I looked into it and, like, there is not the widely availabilityness of, like, limes or birds. Like, they have scooters and bikes. Like, when we were in Copenhagen, a couple times we just hopped on a lime bike, which, like, you can just whip out your phone, you scan a QR code, and you're off to the races. I think in the Netherlands, they're less available because everyone just has so many bikes, personally. So if you're not from here, you kind of just are screwed a little bit.
但你也不会太倒霉，因为 Uber 通常没那么糟糕。只是今天刚好火车出了问题。我从会议的联合组织者 Andrew 那儿听说，有人——我不知道他们离得有多远——本来打算坐火车，结果火车坏了，他们就直接骑车过来了。我问有多远，答案是他只迟到了 30 分钟。我是说 Andrew 说得对，我们确实可以走完全程，但我猜这个人是骑了一辆专业的公路车，
But you're not screwed because Uber typically is not that bad. it just happened to be that the trains weren't working today and I heard actually from Andrew one of the co-organizers of the conference that someone I don't know how far away they were but they were going to train in and then the train was broken so they just cycled in and I asked how far and the answer was he was only 30 minutes late I mean Andrew's right actually there we could get the full distance but I am imagining that this person like hopped on like a serious road bike
在路上做了次不错的锻炼才到这儿的。但不幸的是，没有那种供外国人租用的自行车。但这怪我们。我们应该自己买自行车的。你得有执照才能骑荷兰自行车。那是真的。我们还和某人聊过，他说在布雷达车站确实有自行车可以租，但你需要一张小身份证或支付卡。你不能只用手机和 App 搞定。
and did like a decent workout on the way here but unfortunately there is not the availability of these bikes for foreigners. But it's our fault. We should have bought our own bikes. You have to be certified to have a Dutch bike. That's true. We also talk to someone that said they do have at the Brayda station bikes that you can get, but you need like a little ID card or like payment card. You can't just like do it with your cell phone and an app.
总之，我们爱荷兰。我们爱自行车。我其实比阿姆斯特丹更喜欢布雷达，因为你不会在这里被骑车的人或一群骑车的人撞死。阿姆斯特丹是……公交车是……公交车……哦等等，我们得去赶公交车。等等，我们为什么要录这个，Mark Harris？
Anyways, we love the Netherlands. We love the bike. And I actually like Brita a little bit more than Amsterdam because you're not going to get killed here by a cyclist or a cohort of cyclist. Amsterdam is the bus is the bus Oh wait we got to go to the bus Wait why are we recording this Mark Harris
那是 Bryce 说他是“扫描人”（scan man）的时候，Mark Harris 就浮现在脑海里，因为他有所有的扫描论文。Bryce 刚才在说……我不知道为什么麦克风一直在旁边……就是他……哦，其实我们要曝光他吗？我们只说他住在澳大利亚的山里。
That's when when Bryce said he was the scan man And Mark Harris came to mind Because he has all the scam papers Bryce was just saying And I don't know why the mic's just been by my side Is that he Oh actually do we want to docks him We'll just say he lives in the hills of Australia
但 Mark 讲过一些疯狂的……因为 Mark 是个 PIC，也就是机长（Pilot in Command），负责任的人。我不知道确切的缩写是什么。机长，对。虽然我和 Jake 以及很多人都为 Rapids 工作，那是我待的第一个……是的，好吧，机长。
But Mark has told some crazy Because Mark was a pick Which is a pilot in command person in charge I don't know what the actual acronym Pilot in Command yeah And while both myself and Jake and a bunch of folks work for Rapids, that's where I spent the first... Yeah, well, pilot in command.
他就是那种类似 IC（独立贡献者），但同时又是导师的人……其实我不知道。我只是……PIC 是指在 NVIDIA 负责特定事物的人。比如，它可以是一个功能、一个产品、一个活动，或者一个目标。PIC 的理念是，他们应该……对于任何给定的事物，应该只有一个 PIC，这样才能明确谁负责这件事。
It's just the person that is like an IC, but is a mentor at the same... Actually, I don't know. I'm just... The pick is the person who is responsible for a particular thing at NVIDIA. Like, it could be a feature, it could be a product, it could be like an event, it could be a goal. And the idea of a pick is that they're supposed to... to be just one pick for any given thing so that it's clear who is in charge
我们到对的地方了吗？我正想说，我只看到另外一个人。我想 Mark 是 Rapids 内存管理器（RMM）的 PIC，但我其实不太确定。我得到了好几个肯定的回答，所以。任何时候你问 NVIDIA 的人谁是 PIC，
of the thing. Are we at the right place? I was going to say is I only see one other person. What was, I think Mark was the pick of Rapids Memory Manager RMM, but I don't actually fully know. I'm getting multiple yeses so. Anytime you hear somebody, anytime you ask somebody at NVIDIA who the pick is
如果他们说不止一个人，那就意味着我在 NVIDIA 待的时间还不够长。好了。任何事情都应该只有一个 PIC。好了，一个 PIC。总之，我是说，我们应该请 Mark 来，聊聊扫描，然后他可以亲自讲这个故事。他……是的，是的，说你刚才说的那些，别多说。关于蟒蛇的故事。所以，我保证每个听众都在想 Python 指的是编程语言。
and they say that it's more than one person that means I haven't been at NVIDIA very long time. All right. It's supposed to be one pick for any given thing. All right, one pick. Anyways, there's a, I mean, we should have Mark on, one to talk about scans, but then he can tell this story himself. He, yeah, yeah, say what you just said and nothing more. The Python story. So every listener, I guarantee you, is thinking that Python refers to the programming language.
并不是。它指的是归巢蟒蛇，据说能长到几米长。那是……准确吗？Mark 讲过这个故事，我肯定他跟你讲过，他也跟我讲过，每隔一段时间，因为他住在澳大利亚的山里，这些蟒蛇就会出现在他后院，他不得不——我不知道怎么做到的——但他会以某种方式收集这些蟒蛇，
It does not. It refers to homing pythons that apparently can get up to several meters in length. Is that, that's accurate? And Mark tells this story, I'm sure he's told it to you, he's told to me, where, every once in a while because he lives in the hills of Australia, these pythons show up in his backyard, and he has to, I don't know how, but he collects the python somehow,
把它们扔进我猜是卡车的后斗里，因为那是运蟒蛇合适的交通工具。然后他会开车，真的开几百——也许不是几百，但一百公里。他告诉我的故事是，第一次他开车开了 40 公里把蛇放了，结果那家伙又回来了。所以下一次，
throws it in the back of what I assume is a truck, because that would be the right vehicle for a python. And then he'll drive it like literally hundreds, maybe not hundreds, but a hundred. So the story that he told me was like the first time he took it and he drove it like 40 kilometers and he dropped it off, and then the sucker came back. And so the next stuff,
他研究了它们能归巢多远。网上说如果你把它带到 60 公里外，应该就没事了。结果它还是回来了。是的。到最后，蟒蛇就成了你的宠物，你知道吗？
He researched how far they can home And like the internet said like If you take it like 60 kilometers It should be good And then it kept coming back Yeah At some point the python just becomes your pet You know?
如果它回来这么久，它就是你的……我不知道他是怎么知道那是同一条蟒蛇的，但我只是假设当你住在澳大利亚足够久，你就能分辨出蟒蛇的区别。各位，这就是为什么我今年要第一次去澳大利亚，
If it's coming back that long It's just your... I don't know how he knew That it was the same python But I just assume that when you lived in Australia Long enough you can tell the python's part And this folks is why I will be going to Australia for the first time this year
我有点害怕，因为他们有所有最致命的蜘蛛，比如……你甚至知道掉落熊（drop bears）吗？那是个笑话。那是对考拉的戏称。
and I'm a little bit scared because they have like all the deadliest spiders like... And you even know about the drop bears? That's a joke. Those are a reference
我会说它们其实也挺邪恶的。它们很可爱。但如果你真的去谷歌搜索，或者查看节目说明——我忘了，我们有播客。在节目说明里放上链接，
to koala bears. And I will say they're actually pretty evil as well. They're very cute. But if you actually just Google or actually link in the show notes, I forgot, we have a podcast. Linking the show notes
放一个考拉在地上发出那种声音的视频，它们在呼唤父母时发出的声音太可怕了。在某些情况下很可爱。而且它们大部分时间其实都处于“嗨”的状态，因为它们只吃桉树叶，
to a video of a koala bear on the ground going they make the most awful sound when they're crying for their parents. So cute in sun circumstances. And they're actually mostly high a lot of the time. because they just live off of eucalyptus,
那是一种致癌物，或者我不知道。总之，我是说，Sean 在这儿。我们要不要转回采访 Sean？我们之前试着采访 Sean，但他当时被……“潜逃”（absconded）是正确的词吗？“潜逃”是正确的词。在节目说明里放上那个词的定义，
which is some kind of carcinogen or, I don't know. Anyways, I mean, we have Sean here. Should we rotate back to interviewing Sean? So we tried to interview Sean earlier, but he was being, is absconded the correct word? Absconded is the correct word. Absconded is the correct word. Linking the show knows to a definition of that word,
如果你不知道它是什么意思的话。韦氏词典、牛津词典之类的。也许我们给它个拼字游戏词典。就是这样。我觉得如果人们不知道这个词，他们需要提高词汇量。你的短语，“潜逃”是个好的拼字游戏词吗？你能得很多分。它不是个很棒的拼字游戏词，但我相信 abscond 是七个字母。
if you don't know what it means. Miriam Webster, Oxford or something. Maybe we'll give it the Scrabble Dictionary. There you go. I think people need to up their vocabulary if they don't know the word. Your phrase, abscond did a good scrabble word? You get a lot of points. It's not a great scrabble word, but abscond, I believe, is seven letters.
如果我算错了，那就是八个。但 A, B, S……不，是七个字母。所以那是个宾果（Bingo）。所以即使其中分值最高的字母是 C 或 B，如果你能拼出来，你还能额外得到 50 分。而且，它很有可能是个宾果，因为大多数字母都是单分值的，
If my math is wrong, then it's eight. But A, B, S... No, it's seven letters. So that's a bingo. So even though the highest scoring letter in that is going to be the C or the B, you're going to get an extra 50 points if you can spell that. And also, too, it's going to be a high probability, bingo, because most of them are one-letter tiles,
你更有可能在你的架子上拿到那些。不过没有 E。在 abscond 里，如果你只有两个元音，B-S-C-N-D。你能发现吗？我不能。我也不能。我没那么厉害。
and you're more likely to have those on your rack. There's no E, though. And abscond, if you had only two vowels, and B-S-C-N-D. Are you going to be able to spot that? Not me. Not me either. I'm not that good.
而且，你也会假设 S 会放在最后。除非……有没有像 Bacons，Bacons 加个 D？我不知道。总之，我们在采访 Sean Perrin，不是在聊拼字游戏。不过他确实被很多人“潜逃”了。他们问你什么了？我是说，没有介绍。他不需要介绍。
And also, too, the S, you would assume is going to go at the end. And unless, is there like a Bacons, a Bacons plus a D? I don't know. Anyways, we're interviewing Sean Perrin here, not talking about Scrabble. He was absconded, though, by a lot of folks. What were they asking you? So, I mean, no introduction. He doesn't need one.
他是开场主旨演讲嘉宾，我们几个月前和你聊过你的演讲，现在我们在这儿面对面。你被“潜逃”是因为什么？他们是在问你的演讲还是其他事情？主要是关于我的演讲，是的。还有我用 ST Lab 在做什么，我们聊了一些他们的演讲，有些人是演讲者，有些人只是提问的参会者。所以，是的，很好。
He was opening keynote, and we talked to you about your keynote a couple months ago, now we're here in person. What were you being absconded? Were they asking questions about your talk or about other things? Mostly about my talk, yeah. And what I'm doing with ST Lab and we talked some about their talks, some of them were speakers, some of them were just attendees asking questions. So, yeah, it was good.
很好。好问题。好问题。很棒的问题。是的。你觉得这次怎么样，这是你第一次参加 C++ Under the Sea，对吧？是的。
It was good. Good questions. Good questions. Great questions. Yeah. And how have you found, this is your first time C++ under the C, correct? It is. Yeah.
你觉得呢？还有一个人，所以。那是真的。而且你，我们在这儿。我问了那个问题，我知道答案。我喜欢，我们在这儿。他不在。因此。
How would you? One other, so. That's true. And you, and we were here. I asked that question, and I knew the answer. I like, we were here. He wasn't. Therefore.
我在那儿。我只是坐在后排角落，所以你没看见我。是的，对 Sean Parenthood 来说从来没有。我觉得你永远没机会坐在后排角落。所以感觉如何？是个好会议吗？是个好会议，是的。我很享受。
I was here. I was just sitting in the back corner, so you didn't see me. Yeah, said to Sean Parenthood never. I don't think you ever get to sit in the back corner. So how was it? Was a good conference? It was a good conference, yeah. I enjoyed it.
场地不错。有点偏远。离酒店有点太远了。但，是的，很有趣。这是我们唯一说的一点，我是说，Uber 从来不是问题，等等，但那是我们吗？看起来像公共汽车，那辆看起来像非公共汽车。伙计，这会是最……我们当时在楼里，然后我们在公交车站。
A good venue. A little remote. So a little too far from the hotel. But, yeah, it was fun. That is the only thing that we were saying is that, I mean, it was never a problem with the Uber. and whatnot but is this us that looks like a public bus that one looks like a non-public bus man where this is going to be the most we were we were in the building then we were at the bus stop
我正想说，我们差点也丢了那个人，他直接冲到那辆公交车前面，好像那不是公交车一样。呃，我是说，再次，我看到那个人，他对我做了一个手势，横过喉咙，我不确定那意味着那不是公交车，还是他差点丢了性命。
i was going to say we almost lost that guy too he just darted in front of that bus as if it wasn't a bus uh i mean like like again i see the guy he's giving me a uh a hand across the throat, which is I'm not sure if that means that's not the bus or he almost lost his life.
他在转身。那是基于。总之，有点偏远。这是……我想你以前去过荷兰作为……哦等等。从来没有。
He's turning around. That's based on. Anyway, so a little bit remote. Is this, I imagine you've been to the Netherlands as a... Oh wait. Never.
从来没有。真的？第一次来荷兰。第一次来荷兰。我在阿姆斯特丹吗？是的，你不在。我应该在，但我不在。所以，我来这儿的路上在苏黎世待了一段时间。
Never. Really? First time to the Netherlands. First time to the Netherlands. I'm in Amsterdam? Yeah, you are not. I should, but I am not. So, I spent some time in Zurich on the way here.
哦，是的。你在……我们上次采访你时聊过这个，苏黎世 C++ 聚会。感觉如何，做同样的演讲，对吧？同样的演讲，是的。太棒了。你应该确保我们了解……公交车是公共汽车，还是会议专用的私人巴士？
Oh, yeah. You were at the... We talked about this when we last interviewed you, the Zurich C++ Meetup. How was that, giving the same talk, correct? Same talk, yeah. Amazing. You should make sure we have an understanding of... Is the bus coming in the public bus, or is it the private conference bus?
我想另一辆……我是说，另一辆……我是说，我们不可能刚好错过了公交车，各位。我们马上就会知道。抱歉，Sean。史上最混乱的一集。总之，第一次来荷兰，你刚才在瑞士参加苏黎世 C++ 聚会。是的。
I think the other... I mean, the other... I mean, we can't have just missed the bus, folks. We're about to find out. Sorry, Sean. The most chaotic episode ever. Anyways, first time in the Netherlands, you were just in Switzerland at the Zurich C++ meetup. Yes.
瑞士很美。你以前去过瑞士吗？没有，第一次。第一次去瑞士和荷兰。这次旅行我在我的清单上增加了两个国家。你有清单吗？你知道你去过多少个国家吗？我试着加起来。
Switzerland is beautiful. Have you been to Switzerland before? No, first time. First time to both Switzerland and Netherlands. I added two countries to my check-off list here on this trip. Do you have a list? Do you know how many countries you've been to? I was trying to add it up.
我想是，嗯，我在 10 个国家做过演讲，所以，是的。好的。所以，我想这是第 9 个和第 10 个？第 9 和第 10。就是这样。我很确定我演讲过的国家更多。但你还有几年。我……
I think it's, well, I've spoken in 10 countries, so, yeah. Okay. So that, I guess this was 9 in 10? Nine and 10. There you go. I'm pretty sure more countries I've spoken in. But you've got a few years. I'm...
哦，好的。你能帮我们吗？好，说吧。嘿。那是公交车吗？是吗？是的。过来。
Oh, okay. Can you help us? Good, speak such. Hey. Is that a bus? Yeah? Yeah. Come here.
你得走了。好的。所以，我们移动？是的。哦，好的。那意味着我们错过了公交车还是……我想我们站错地方了。好的。
You have to go. Okay. So, we move? Yes. Oh, okay. Does that mean we miss the bus or... I think we're standing in the wrong place. Okay.
但公交车还在路上吗？我想是。我是说，他只是在笑，所以……我不确定这是好兆头还是坏兆头。有个标志。有他自己的车。哦，看看这些车。等等，等等。
But the bus is still on route? I think so. I mean, he's just laughing, so... I'm not sure that's a good sign or a bad sign. There's a sign. has his own vehicle. Ooh, look at these cars. Wait, wait.
我们要去哪儿？我跑过去。好的。好的。我知道还有另一站。这是什么？我要走了，所以。哦，你要走了。
Where we're going? I'll run there. Okay. Okay. I know there is another stop. This is what? I'm going to leave so. Oh, you're going to leave.
我以为你在要麦克风。很高兴。你有车，所以你开车回家。是的，先生。好的。我们可能一年后再见。祝婚礼顺利。是的，是的，谢谢。
I thought you were asking for the mic. It was a pleasure. You had a car, so you're driving home. Yes, sir. All right. We'll see you potentially in a year. Good luck with the wedding. Yeah, yeah, thank you.
我们要不要考虑去……谢谢你的视频。谢谢见到你。是的。好吧，他的车里没地方了，所以。好的。很高兴见到你，是的。太棒了。
Should we potentially take up going on to all? Thank you for a video. Thank you for meeting you. Yeah. Well, there's not enough room in his car, so. All right. It was good seeing, yeah. Awesome.
嘿，干杯。是的。谢谢你的 PR。Parr Repro 上的第一个 PR。哦，真的吗？是的，是的。第一个是把它变成绿色。哦，那是真的。
Hey, cheers. Yeah. And thank you for the PR. First PR on the Parr Repro. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. First was to turn it green. Oh, that's true.
嗯，不，他没有开 PR。他只是开了一个 issue。好的。你没有，你还没有提交过 PR。你试图表现得像，我提交了一个 PR。好的，继续。好的。很高兴再次见到你，Koon。
Well, no, he did not open a PR though. He just opened an issue. Okay. You didn't, you have not submitted PRs. You're trying to be like, I submitted a PR. Okay, go ahead. All right. Good seeing you again, Koon.
很高兴再次见到你，Kuh。混乱中夹杂着信息。哦，在那边。那是我们的公交车吗？好了，各位。我们可以看到远处有一辆公交车。我们善良的小帮手。哦不，它要走了。
Good seeing you again, Kuh. chaos with sprinkles of information Oh way over this Is that our bus? All right folks We can see a bus in the distance And our good little help Oh no it's leaving
为什么他不冲过去追它？我不知道。等等，Kuhn 去哪儿了？那是公交车吗？好的，为什么我们不去找到 Kuhn？半小时。哦，天哪。所以你失败了。
Why didn't he sprint after it I don't know Wait where did Kuhn go Was that the bus? Okay why don't we go find Kuhn? Half an hour. Oh, my God. So you fail.
去抓住 Kuhn。什么？去跑着抓住 Kuhn。你是跑步者。去跑吧。我们要怎么办，部分地？但否则我们得打两辆车。为什么我们不去抓 Kuhn？
Go grab Kuhn. What? Go run and grab Kuhn. You're a runner. Go running. What are we going to do, though, partially? But otherwise we're going to have to get two cabs. Why don't we go get Kuhn?
因为那样他可以带我们中的一些人。他在那边某处。跑，伙计，跑。天哪，伙计，说他是跑步者。实际上并不听指挥跑步。不，没关系。Connor 会找到他的。Connor 会找到他的。
Because then he can take some of us. He's somewhere over there. Run, man, run. Jeez, man, said he's a runner. Doesn't actually run on command. No, it's fine. Connor will find him. Connor will find him.
Connor 跑。他就像……看看这个。所以现在我们知道 Connor 是怎么跑的了。是的，现在我们知道 Connor 是怎么跑的了。哦，我不相信他跑了 20 公里。是的，是的，我也觉得很难相信。
Connor run He's like Look at this So now we know how Connor runs Yes now we know how Connor runs Oh I don't believe he put in 20 kilometers Yeah yeah I find that hard to believe too
但我猜最坏的情况，我们只是……我们只是打辆车。他那样跑了 20 公里，这就是为什么他早些时候说他有一天放松的时间。我对 Connor 有信心。我是说，他的包在这儿，所以我认为他会。我猜他会回来的。
But I guess worst case we'll just We'll just get a cab He ran 20 kilometers like that Which is why he's walked earlier it was saying he had a day of relaxation. I have faith in Connor. I mean, his bag is here, so I think he will. I would guess he will come back.
我今天已经吃了大约五个 ASML 华夫饼了。好的，明白了。华夫饼有很多种。你想说说华夫饼和焦糖煎饼（stroopwafels）的区别吗？我是说。听众感兴趣吗？我不……他们最好感兴趣。
I've already had like five of the ASML waffles today. Okay, understood. There are many types of waffles. Do you want to tell the difference between waffles and stroff waffles? I mean. A listener's interested? I don't... They better be.
告诉我们区别。这种焦糖煎饼，中间有蜂蜜。大约半厘米宽。真正的华夫饼大约两厘米宽，上面有时有巧克力和很多糖。好的，明白了，明白了。在美国人眼里，那些都不是华夫饼。它们是小……华夫饼是你放进华夫饼机里的东西。
Tell us the difference. So this straw waffle, it has honey in the middle. It's like half a centimeter wide. And real waffles are like two centimeter wide, and they have sometimes chocolate on the top and a lot of sugar. Okay, understood, understood. To American eyes, none of those are waffles. They're little... A waffle is a thing that you put into a waffle line.
铁板，呃，你可能会放蓝莓，可能会放巧克力豆，然后你放一些真正的美国枫糖浆，不是那种加拿大枫糖浆。你想要一些吗？你想要一些吗？是的，最好的枫糖浆来自佛蒙特州。这是加拿大的东西。不，不，等等，你最喜欢的枫糖浆是什么？明尼苏达。明尼苏达。我也会……那对我来说也是一个可以接受的答案。我甚至不知道还有明尼苏达枫糖浆。哦，是的，我有一个远房表亲在明尼苏达做枫糖浆，还有野米。哦，那是个有趣的组合。好的。
iron and uh you maybe put blueberries in you maybe put chocolate chips in and then you put some real american maple syrup none of that Canadian maple syrup you want some you want some yes the best maple syrup is from Vermont this was a Canadian thing no no wait what's your preferred maple syrup Minnesota Minnesota I would that's also I think an acceptable answer to me I did not know that there was even Minnesota uh maple syrup oh yeah I have a distant cousin who does maple syrup in Minnesota along with wild rice. Oh, that is an interesting combination. Okay.
你没有把它放在一起，他卖的时候是不同的季节。我想是的。是的，所以。Connor 还没回来。我开始担心了。就像我说的，他找到了车。是的。我们被困住了。
You don't have it together, different seasons when he sells it. I would imagine, yes. Yeah, so. Connor is still not returned. I'm starting to grow concerned. Like I said, he found a ride Yeah We're stranded
是的。你从哪儿弄到的这个 Nvidia？这个 Nvidia 抓绒衣？是从装备店买的吗？是的。好的，那很好。我是在 GTC 上买的。
Yeah Where did you get that Invidia This Nvidia puffered? Is that from the gear store? Yeah Okay, that's nice I got it at GTC
啊，是的。是的，圣何塞。是的，在圣何塞。是的。可惜我们没有字母夹克，对吧？
Ah, yeah Yeah San Jose Yeah In San Jose Yeah Too bad we don't have Letter checkettes right
但我们在公司有那个。那会是装备店里不错的东西。是的，但 CEO 说不。Adobe 有好的周边吗？我是说，因为 Adobe 也是一家以视觉艺术闻名的公司，所以我猜会有好的材料。是的，我们有相当不错的周边，但我们从没机会去参加会议，所以。
But we have that at a company That would be a nice thing have in the gear store. Yeah, but like the CEO says no. Does Adobe have good swag? I am at, because Adobe's also a company known for the visual art, so I would imagine having good, good material. Yeah, we have pretty good swag, but we never get to go to the conferences, so.
哦，真的吗？你是说 Adobe 会议？Adobe 会议。因为那些是给创作者，给用户的？是的，那些是给创作者给用户的。但谁来做关于 Photoshop 新功能之类的演讲呢？是的，所以通常。那可能是些高管，但也会有，我们有很多创意艺术总监担任那个角色。
Oh, really? To the Adobe conferences, you mean? The Adobe conferences. Because those are for the creators, for users? Yeah, those are for the creators for the users. But who gives the talks about the new features in Photoshop and things like that? Yeah, so usually. That might be some executives, but it will also be, we have a lot of creative art directors who take on that role.
Adobe 没有像 Adobe 开发者大会那样的东西吗？我是说，Photoshop 以插件闻名。是的，你会觉得我们应该有。也许我们得办一个。好的。我听到声音了。是的，我想他会回来的。我看到有人在跑。
And Adobe doesn't have like an Adobe developer conference? I mean, like Photoshop's known for the whole plugin. Yeah, you would think we would. Maybe we'll have to start one. Okay. I'm hearing things. Yeah, I guess he will come around. I see people running.
那才是真正的跑步，不像 Conner 的，不像 Conner 的跑步。这是我们的公交车吗？不是。所以等等，等等，什么？Connor 在那儿吗？好的。这辆车能坐多少人？所有的美国人。
That was a proper run, unlike Conner's, unlike Conner's run. Is this our bus? No. So wait, wait, wait, what? Is Connor there? Okay. How many people will fit in this vehicle? All the Americans.
我们坐公交车。我想你联系不上 Daniel？我想他没接。哦不，等等，我很好，我坐公交车。哦，我们在那儿，好的。你可以再说一遍。
We take the bus. I guess you couldn't reach Daniel? I think he didn't answer Oh no wait like I'm fine I'm taking the bus Oh there we are okay You get to say that again
那是你的，对吧？是的。我们正在把混乱带到一个全新的地狱水平。在这一集里。我们要去多少人？只是三个吗？然后还有另一辆 Uber？不，公交车 10 分钟后到。
That's yours right Yes We're taking chaos to a whole new hell level On this episode How many people are we going with Is it just three or And then there's going to be another Uber No the bus comes in 10 minutes
所以我坐公交车。我看到公交车了。你不想坐前排吗？你确定？我坐。你觉得你是最高的，对吧？我向你保证 Sean 是最高的，但同时，
So I'll take the bus I see the bus you don't want to take the front shot you're sure I do you think you're the tallest is that right I promise you Sean is the tallest but also too
必须有一个年龄因素，在这里你可以，你可以拿着它。我不想说资历，因为那听起来……但它听起来，听起来，就说年龄。
there has to be a factor of age and here you can you can hold it I don't want to say seniority because that sounds but it sounds it sounds just say age
我不想说年龄。这老实说，这是……我是说，Coots 可能在想，该死，我刚从这之前的两集过来，现在我们在我的车里录音。这会是传奇的。我听说很多，很多当我在问他们喜欢会议什么时，很多人说他们觉得有点像……等等，我们可以，我们可以倒回去吗？发生了什么？他们只是听到了一堆噪音。好的，我们在 Kuzk。好的，切掉。上帝，他跑得不够快。好的，其他人同意。他会听录音的。那是录下来的。
I don't want to say age this is honestly it's uh i mean coots probably thinking god damn i just went from two episodes before this is and now we're recording in my car this is going to be legendary i heard a lot of a lot of people when i was asking what they liked about the conference and what a lot of people said that they think something to the effect of wait can we can we do can we back up what's happened they just heard a bunch of noise okay we're in kuzk all right cut god wasn't running fast enough okay other people agreed he'll listen to the tape that was recorded
当你离开的时候。我们现在在 Coon 的车里。Coon 开车带我们去布雷达中心。我离开的时候聊到这个了吗？我想是的，是的。好吧，你离开的事实被聊到了。有些人以为你可能抛弃了我们。哦，因为花了
when you were gone. We're now in Coon's car. Coons driving us into the center of Brita. Was that covered while I was gone? I think so, yeah. Well, the fact that you were gone was covered. Some people thought that you may have abandoned us. Oh, because it took a
一秒钟找到他们，因为停车场很大，而且……如果你跑得快点，问题就不会那么大了。但是，很多人评论说你的演讲让他们开始思考泛型编程以及泛型编程意味着什么。
second to find them because the parking was pretty big and... If you'd run faster, it would have been less of a problem. But so a lot of people commented that your talk got them thinking about generic programming and what generic programming means.
我想也许你可以和更广泛的听众分享一下你对泛型编程意味着什么的看法，因为我觉得很多人只是意味着我使用模板。是的，所以我有两个幻灯片。一个是泛型编程不是元编程，用泛型编程也不是泛型编程。泛型编程背后的思想是编程是数学，
And I thought maybe you could share your thoughts with the wider audience on what generic programming means because I think a lot of people just means that I use a template. Yeah, so I had two slides. One is that generic programming is not metaprogramming, and programming with generics is not generic programming. The ideas behind generic programming are that programming is mathematics,
它是建立在这个概念上的。概念，这与我们语言中的概念概念有点不同，尽管初衷是代表相同的基本思想。但概念是相关需求的集合，它在数学上等同于代数结构。算法是在概念上定义的。是的，所以这是谈论我们如何表达这些需求，类型建模这些需求意味着什么的主要重点。所以，是的，如果你想了解更多，我会让 Connor 链接到这本书。
and it's built on this note. of a concept, which is a little different than the language notion we have of a concept, although the intention was to represent the same basic idea. But concept is a collection of related requirements, and it's the equivalent in mathematics to an algebraic structure. And algorithms then are defined on concepts. Yeah, so that was the main thrust in talking about how we express those requirements, what it means for a type to model those requirements. So, yeah, if you want to learn more, I'll have Connor a link to the book.
还有，等等，让我想想同样的。还有，各位，我不知道它是宝石还是粗糙的隐藏。我不知道你的 Pacific C++ 演讲有多少观看量。它被剪辑在我的 2019 年算法直觉演讲中。它是，我是说，你有这么多好的演讲，但它名列前茅。前三名，嗯，我知道吗？前三，前五。这是 Sean 最好的演讲之一。
Also, wait, let me think of the same. Also, too, folks, I don't know if it's a gem or a hidden in the rough. I don't know how many views your Pacific C++ talk is. it was clipped in my algorithm intuition in 2019 talk. And it is one of the, it's, I mean, it's, you have so many good talks, but it's up there. Top three for, well, do I know? Top three, top five. It's one of Sean's best talks.
因为那是第一次，你说了好多次，但这只是我观看你演讲的顺序，你提到了优美的代码。而且它确实有某种东西，我不知道那个词是什么，比如，不是解放，但当你听到像你这样有经验的人谈论代码的美感时，Stepanov 也经常这样做，但我当时还没看过他的任何内容。我一直以为我是少数派，
Because that was where the first time, and you said it a bunch of times, but it's just the order that I watched your toxin, where you refer to beautiful code. And it is, there is something, I don't know what the word is, like, not liberating, but like, when you hear someone with as much experience as you talking about the beauty of code and Stepanov does it a bunch but I haven't watched any of his content at that point in time I had always thought that I was like in the minority
关于代码外观的美学很重要，因为我没听过其他人谈论它。但后来你做了这个叫“泛型编程”的演讲，在 Pacific C++，这是一个我相信已经不存在的会议。我不知道你是否认为这个演讲是对 Alex Stepanov 的致敬，但你提到了他的算法和，那是什么，稳定排序（stable sort）。是那个吗？是的，稳定排序是那个算法。
of like the aesthetics of what code looks like is important because I hadn't heard anyone else talk about it but then you were giving this talk called generic programming at Pacific C++ which is a conference that I believe no longer exists and it was I don't know if you consider the talk like an homage to Alex Stepanon but you referred to his algorithm and the, what was it, stable sort. Was that the, yes, stable sort was the algorithm.
那是你当时说的那一刻，你知道，这是一段优美的代码，你知道，被列在解决难题的清单上。他只用了几行代码就完成了。而且像你一样，我清楚地记得那句引语。那是我在演讲中剪辑的内容，就是你说，我看到这段代码，然后，那是，那是我想要写的代码。我想学习如何，你怎么写出这样的代码？而且在任何其他编程语言会议，任何技术上，
And that was the moment where you were saying, you know, it's this beautiful piece of code that, you know, was considered, it was on some list of hard problems to solve. And he did it in like a few lines of code. And like you, I remember explicitly the quote. That was what I clipped in the talk, which was you saying, like, I saw this code and, like, that's, that is the code that I want to write. I want to learn how to, how do you write code like this? and like in no other talk at any other programming language conference whatever technology
我从未听过任何人那样充满激情和强调地谈论算法或一段代码的美学和美感。总之，如果你对 Sean 刚才在主旨演讲中谈论的内容感兴趣，你一定要去看看 Pacific C++ 的泛型编程类型。你在其他地方做过吗，还是那是唯一的录音？总之，我会把麦克风交还给你，因为我觉得那可能是唯一的录音。那个演讲是我专门准备的，我受邀在 Pacific C++ 做主旨演讲，恰逢泛型编程 30 周年。所以那是 Alex Steppenoff 和 Dave Musser 提出
have I ever heard anyone talk that like passionately and emphatically about like the aesthetic and the beauty of an algorithm or a piece of code anyway so if you are interested in what Sean was just talking about in this keynote you should definitely go check out the Pacific C++ generic programming type did you give it anywhere else or is that the only recording of it anyways I'll hand the mic back to you because I think that might be the only recording of it that talk was I put together specifically I got in invited to give a keynote at Pacific C++, and it happened to coincide with the 30th anniversary of generic programming. So it was 30 years after Alex Steppenoff and Dave Musser coined the term
泛型编程 30 年后。我觉得非常有必要对泛型编程的历史、起源及其存在意义进行一次恰当的梳理。所以我准备了那场演讲，我对此感到非常自豪，因为我在演讲前请 Alex 审阅过，Alex 的评价是他自己也做不到更好。所以，是的，那是让我最自豪的演讲之一。我会说这是一个非常好的演讲，节目说明里有链接，节目说明里有链接。我正想说的是，你也应该链接到《从数学到泛型编程》，也就是 Alex 和 Dan Rose 的书，
generic programming. And I thought it really deserved a proper covering of kind of the history of generic programming and where it came from and why it's a thing. And so I put together that talk and I'm pretty proud of the talk because I ran it past Alex before I gave it and Alex's comment was that he couldn't do it better himself so yeah so that's that's what are the talks I'm most proud of I would say it's a very good talk link in the show notes link in the show notes what I was going to what I was going to say is you should link to for mathematics to generic programming also which is Alex and Dan Rose's book
它建立了泛型编程和数学之间非常紧密的联系。哦，是的。泛型编程难吗？还是比非泛型编程更难？你知道，这经常被提起，我其实认为不难。它确实需要一些时间来学习和熟悉，但基本思想是学习。去观察
which makes the very strong connection between generic programming and mathematics. Oh, yeah. Is generic programming hard? Or harder than programming non-generically? You know, this comes up a lot, and I actually think not. It does take some amount of time to learn and get familiar with, but the basic idea is learning. to see
什么是必要的操作，忽略所有不必要的操作。而且，你知道，练习了多年，我发现当我写代码时，我倾向于自然而然地以泛型方式编写。仅仅因为它帮助我将其提炼为：什么是基本属性？
what are the necessary operations and ignore all of the unnecessary ones. And, you know, so having practiced it for years, I find when I write code, I tend to write it generically as a matter of course. Just because it helps me distill it down to like, what are the essential properties?
如果我用这些术语来写，我就不会被非本质的属性分心，也不太可能对自己正在做的事情感到困惑。所以我认为那里可能有一点学习曲线，但总的来说，我认为进行适当的泛型编程更容易。
And if I'm writing it in those terms, that I'm not distracted by properties that are not essential and I'm less likely to be confused about what I'm doing. So I think there might be a bit of a learning curve there, but in general I think doing proper generic programming is easier.
你知道，还有对整体部分关系和可变值语义的依赖，内化这些概念意味着你永远不会对对象所有权或在类转换过程中调用某些函数导致的不变性被破坏感到困惑，或者线程安全，所有这些担忧都会消失，它促进了局部推理。现在，嗯，我一直从心理上认为泛型编程可能前期成本更高，
You know, there's also a reliance on whole part relationships and mutable value. semantics and internalizing those concepts means you're never confused about object ownership or about invariance being violated because you called some function in the middle of making a transformation in the middle of a class or threat safety all of those concerns drop away and it promotes local reasoning now it's um i i've always sort of mentally thought that generic programming might have a higher upfront cost,
但编写泛型代码更可持续、更可扩展，它随着时间的推移表现更好。这就是为什么我倾向于第一次就以泛型方式编写事物。虽然我当然听过这种批评，而且我当然也写过可能过度泛化或过度设计的代码，我觉得这是挑战之一，就是知道，就是弄清楚如何定义这个操作或实体需要处理的范围。
but that writing generic code is more sustainable and more scalable, that it holds up better over time. And that's why I tend to write things generically the first time. Although I've certainly heard the criticism made, and I certainly have written code that is maybe over-generalized or over-engineered, and I feel like that's one of the challenges is to know, is to figure out how to define the scope of what this operation or entity needs to handle.
这是弄清楚你试图编写的代码的约束和需求的一部分。约束和需求，以及我认为被忽视太多的部分是弄清楚什么是你概念的有用模型。然后一旦你确定了一些有用的模型，弄清楚这些模型固有的属性是什么，
And that's part of this figuring out the constraints and the requirements of the code that you're trying to write. The constraints and the requirements and the piece that I think is far too often ignored is figuring out what are useful models. of your concepts. And then once you've identified some useful models, figuring out what are those models inherent properties
因为你基本上可以免费获得这些属性。对。甚至我在我的演讲中也涵盖了这一点，关于“常规”（regular）的基本思想存在困惑。我们倾向于将其切分。部分原因是我们在语言中对于如何指定这些事物词汇有限。所以没有办法说某事，
because you basically get those properties then for free. Right. And even I covered it in my talk, there's confusion about just the basic idea of regular. We tend to slice it up. And part of that is because we have a limited vocabulary within the language for how we specify these things. So there's no way to say that something,
因为你基本上可以免费获得这些属性。没错。甚至我在演讲中也提到了，人们对正则的基本概念存在困惑。我们倾向于将其切分，部分原因是我们在语言中对于如何指定这些内容词汇有限。所以没有办法说某件事，
that is copyable, it's required that the copies are equal without requiring the implementation of equal, equal. And I tend to bias on just implement the missing functions on your types, and then go ahead and require them. So I would be a little more opinionated if I were in charge of the standard and there would be a concept regular at the root and we wouldn't have concept copyable, concept movable, concept equality comparable. Those are just all regular, and those are required on most types.
这是可复制的，要求副本相等，而不要求实现相等性（equal）。我倾向于在你的类型上实现缺失的函数，然后直接要求它们。如果我负责标准，我会更主观一些，在根部会有一个“常规”（regular）的概念，而不会有“可复制”、“可移动”、“可相等比较”这些概念。它们都属于“常规”，并且在大多数类型中都是必需的。
And so that you would require that everybody, you would require that everybody provide all those things. Yeah, everybody implements them. Now, that would be much easier if we actually had good default implementations that you didn't have to actually write the code. So that's the direction I take it in, and that's, you know, large, the direction we've been pushing with Hylo is, you know, we just assume regularity. I am
所以你会要求每个人都提供所有这些东西。是的，每个人都实现它们。现在，如果我们确实有好的默认实现，不需要你亲自写代码，那会容易得多。这就是我采取的方向，也是我们在 Hylo 中一直推动的方向，我们只是假设“常规性”。我
sympathetic to the way that the standard structures it today because I have certainly been burned by places in the standard where you are required to provide a certain thing in particular. I'm thinking of like curroutine handle. Like there's a
对标准目前构建它的方式表示同情，因为我确实在标准中的某些地方被坑过，在那些地方你被要求提供特定的东西。我想到的是像协程句柄（coroutine handle）之类的东西。就像有一个
bunch of the exception and error handling functions where you have to provide a definition and you get a compilation error if you don't because this is not a concept thing. This is like a compiler. It's a compiler thing. Yeah, yeah. It's also just like it's this magic type that compiler knows about. And
很多异常和错误处理函数，你必须提供定义，否则会得到编译错误，因为这不是一个概念（concept）层面的东西。这就像是一个编译器层面的东西。是的，是的。它也就像是一个编译器知道的神奇类型。而且
like I just wish that there was a default and the default could have been just like terminated or something but like if I'm just playing around with a curroutine I don't want to have to define the error handling, the exception handling, you know, a piece of it. And it always, it's pained me that we've made those required functions instead of being like let's have a default
我只是希望有一个默认值，默认值可以是终止（terminated）之类的，但如果我只是在玩协程，我不想必须定义错误处理、异常处理的那一部分。这一直让我很痛苦，我们把这些变成了必需的函数，而不是像“让我们有一个默认值”那样。
and and I mean perhaps if we just had more defaults and better defaults it would be easier for us to define whole concepts instead of these sort of piecemeal I don't know what you call copy constructible but you alluded to that it's not really a concept in your talk yeah yeah it's a it's a It's a concept fragment because the concept by definition is a set of connected axioms. And you can't talk about something being copyable without defining what copy means. And to define what copy means, you have to talk about equality. Ah, yes. Right?
我的意思是，也许如果我们有更多的默认值和更好的默认值，我们定义完整的概念就会更容易，而不是像现在这样零敲碎打。我不知道你怎么称呼“可构造拷贝”（copy constructible），但你在演讲中暗示它并不是一个真正的概念。是的，它是一个概念片段，因为概念根据定义是一组相互关联的公理。你不能在不定义“拷贝”意味着什么的情况下谈论“可复制”。而要定义“拷贝”意味着什么，你必须谈论“相等”。啊，是的。对吧？
So, yeah. And there's so many places where these properties compose, right? If all of your parts are copyable, the whole is copyable. of your parts are movable, the whole is movable. So, you know, if all of your parts are ordered, you can at least provide a lexicographical ordering by default. So, so there are reasonable defaults for most of these, most of these cases. These things compose pretty well. so, you know, a lot of the pushback on some of these things from the Standards Committee
所以，是的。而且这些属性在很多地方是可以组合的，对吧？如果你的所有部分都是可复制的，那么整体就是可复制的。如果你的所有部分都是可移动的，那么整体就是可移动的。所以，如果你的所有部分都是有序的，你至少可以默认提供字典序。所以，对于大多数这些情况，都有合理的默认值。这些东西组合得非常好。所以，标准委员会对其中一些事情的很多抵制
has been well, we don't want a default or we don't want a default that's confusing but if you kind of step back to first principles, I don't think the defaults are confusing and they compose well. Wait, wait, wait, wait, or do you want to do this outside? Wait, so the silent hero of this episode has been Kuhn, who's been,
是基于“我们不想要一个默认值”或者“我们不想要一个令人困惑的默认值”，但如果你退一步从第一性原理来看，我不认为这些默认值令人困惑，而且它们组合得很好。等等，等等，或者你想在外面做这个？等等，所以这一集的无名英雄是 Kuhn，他一直……
Thank you for driving us. I assume everyone mentioned that the bus we missed. I mean, you can grab your stuff out of the back. But if you want any final things to say, here's your moment, the silent hero of episode, whatever, 260, whatever this is. It's been my pleasure. Happy to help. All right, thanks so much, Kuhn.
谢谢你载我们。我假设每个人都提到了我们错过的公交车。我的意思是，你可以从后面拿走你的东西。但如果你有什么最后的话要说，现在是你的时刻，第260集（或者不管这是第几集）的无名英雄。这是我的荣幸。很高兴能帮忙。好的，非常感谢，Kuhn。
I think we are trapped too. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com For links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. We'll see you next year.
我想我们也困在这里了。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。明年见。
All right, Coon, you're a lifesaver, or at least you saved half of us, and we'll see you again. We've got to come back now next year because you're our most. We've had a few different listeners on, But none is a story to journey as yours From recording to We've never recorded in a car before I don't think there's also There's a Belgian C++ You know
好的，Coon，你是救星，或者至少你救了我们一半人，我们还会再见面的。明年我们必须回来，因为你是我们最……我们请过几位不同的听众，但没有人的故事像你这样，从录制到……我想我们以前从来没在车里录过音。还有，还有一个比利时 C++……你知道
That's what actually I was thinking I think we should Not focus on conferences so much And just start We should do a circuit of Stockholm Has this Sweden C++ Hit up the Copenhagen Hit up the Belgian one
我刚才想的正是那个，我觉得我们不应该太关注会议，而应该开始……我们应该做一个斯德哥尔摩巡回，去瑞典 C++，去哥本哈根，去比利时那个。
Yeah I know the organizer of the Belgian one Is it you? Okay No I guess I know the organizer It's me No
是的，我知道比利时那个的组织者。是你吗？好吧，不，我想我知道组织者。是我。不。
Well maybe that's the Maybe that's a, maybe we can do that after some conference next year. Something more reason to be, yeah. All right, get them to say. Thank you so much. Let's see. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，也许这就是……也许我们可以明年在某个会议之后做这件事。更有理由去做，是的。好的，让他们说。非常感谢。让我们看看。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。